very very rarely very rarely a perfect
episode of sci-fi comes along
I'm going to be watching some of those
perfect episodes suggested by yourself
and ones I've picked and I'm going to be
telling you all about them
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel while I watch Firefly out
of gas
thank you
[Music]
first thing I gotta say is that Firefly
is one of my favorite sci-fi shows of
all time
and there are several brilliant
brilliant episodes
um the train job our Mrs Reynolds
Jamestown the song from Jamestown is
just amazing
um aerial War Stories to be honest
almost all of the episodes are absolute
gold
but perfection
is a little bit
more and a beauty in the imperfections
as well it doesn't have to be the best
written the best it's you know when
there's a perfect storm of just
everything comes together
out of gas
is just one of those episodes in any
sci-fi that is just genius it was
written by Tim minir and that
immediately actually fills me with a lot
of confidence because even though Joss
Whedon gets a lot of the credit for
Firefly Tim minir actually did a lot of
the heavy lifting wrote a lot of the
really really brilliant episodes into a
lot of the work now I actually heard a
rumor about eight or nine months ago
that Disney had approached Tim minir
about returning and rebooting Firefly
now a lot of people have said you can't
do it without Joss Whedon my argument is
you can do it without just reading if
you've got Tim veneer now it doesn't
like that rumor actually turned into
anything because not long after I heard
that actually Disney would drop in their
plans to reboot Firefly for now because
they want Nathan Fillion to return and
that's the only way they think the show
can actually succeed is if they're
getting Nathan Fillion back maybe after
the rookie
but when that reboot does happen let's
hope Tim minir is back in the frame
watching sci-fi cup of tea does life get
any better the episode opens with an
empty dead Serenity and then we see Mao
fall into the shot seriously injured but
we don't know why it's one of the
beautiful things about this episode that
it's actually shot in basically three
different bits that intertwine with each
other and tell the story together but
we're hooked immediately with the
mystery of what the hell is going on
yeah we then see Mal come aboard the
strategy with Zoe for the first time
it's very very funny Zoe is not
impressed she won't be winning
time soon but she is solid shipped like
this be with you to the day you die
because it's a death trap that's not
a ship that doesn't run a ship that is
well got stuff living in it
it's not the serenity we've seen before
but it does give us that hint of the
beginning of this series that we love so
much and we get to see more of that as
the dead Serenity that we see at the
beginning slowly becomes the family that
we see at the start of the series
here's the opening credit take me where
I cannot stand I won't sing anymore
They're laughing and they're joking
around the dinner table like any real
family we even see Simon trying to tell
a joke not his Forte but then they bring
him a cake because on The Wire they've
said his birthday because he's a wanted
criminal so of course they have his date
of birth on his uh you know wanted
posters created
I really love that that they bring this
family together
to only them have to fire
a fire the river Seas coming
the whole sequence with the fire when
the engine blows stops running kills the
Serena too basically because I want
small part that's bust is one of the
best scenes in all of firefly from a
special effects point of view the Flames
burn through the ship they seal the
doors and then wash and Mal run up and
they open the main cargo bay suck in all
the air out and sucking the fire out the
serenity ends up breathing fire out into
space it is a seriously cool special
effect
and as I said one of the best ones in
the entire series
crew are scared out of their minds Zoe
one of the strongest characters in the
series is injured and wash doesn't want
to leave aside but Mal tells him he's
got to go up to the bridge he's got to
help them get going again oh they're all
dead wash won't leave his wife and we
get to see another side of Mal now the
side of Mao that probably got him
through the war
the side of Mao that isn't all
lovey-dovey and caring for his family
basically and that's how he considers
the crew of The Serenity his family he
puts wash against the wall and tells him
I'm not asking I am telling you get up
there and do your damn job
throughout this episode we see
flashbacks to how the crew actually
joined the serenity we've already seen
when Zoe first sees the serenity there's
no impressed we then get to see how the
rest of the crew joins now we've already
seen in the first episode the pilot
episode how Shepherd book joined the
crew and how Simon and River joined but
now we get to see wash Jane inara and
Kaylee
first time we see why she has a massive
Ginger mustache and and Zoe basically
says something about him bothers me I
suspect this is one of those times like
my marriage when my go-to beard gets a
little bit longer and the wife says you
bother me and I know that's time to
shave
as I said this episode flashes backwards
and falls through time again now in the
future present Mal has been shot he's
seriously injured we still don't know
what happened but we do know that he's
gonna shoot himself up with adrenaline
from the moment before we see the doctor
shooting a shot of adrenaline directly
into Zoe's heart as he desperately tries
and fights to save her life but Mao is
alone
quite like to have seen more about this
dumbass mechanic that they have that
basically we see diddling uh Kaylee up
against the wall he was quite a fun
character I quite liked him but I do
love this sign because hey Mal why do we
need two mechanics
we really don't and Kaylee joined the
crew Kayla's actually probably my
favorite character in all of this and I
love the actress as well she's um always
on Twitter and my messages quite a lot
more so desperately hopefully she might
reply one day
um but she's just adorable but also
genuinely genius
when she realizes she can't fix the
Serenity and then it kills her because
she almost has a symbiotic relationship
with with this Serenity she actually
says Serenity tells me when there's
something wrong normally
I didn't no I didn't know this I didn't
see it come in Captain I'm so sorry and
she's you know really feels like she's
let everybody down
when we meet inara
we immediately see the
she's face worthy strange sort of
character of Mal that he is so honorable
but then we'll call in our a whole
but then he will call inara a to
her face even though he puts his life at
risk in another episode to save a bunch
of pause
he still doesn't have an issue with
saying that to her face why is that it's
basically because he doesn't think it's
an honorable profession he's an
old-fashioned kind of guy but the next
introduction we see is by far the best
of the introductions of all the family
when we first meet Jane
even though Mal calls her a in the
episode a second ago we then see Mal and
his other side of his personality when
he follows anara onto the shuttle
because they're about to use it to run
and try to survive just a little bit
longer and Nara says get out the way you
don't even know how to use this damn
thing and he's still there looking
checking
he loves inara
he hates what she does for a living
because he's jealous
but he loves the woman
and
not just in a romantic way as I say the
crew of The Serenity in Mal's family and
he is terrified about what's about to
happen
Mal now prepares to go down with the
ship
now an hour says You Don't Have To Die
Alone come with us be with us he says no
you can't the shuttle takes four I can't
come
she says don't be silly what difference
is it gonna make well Mal has already
made his mind up he's already made the
decision that he will stay with Serenity
until the end
that is his home and he always knew he
was going to die alone anyway
and he wasn't going to die anywhere else
other than the serenity
my own savior appears that a radio
signal comes through a ship has detected
a signal they sent out Mr their
navigation and forced them to stop they
then suspiciously carefully arrive
wondering whether this might be some
sort of trap Mal says look you know I'm
dying all I need is this little park and
you can save my life
but then it wanders into might be my
favorite my favorite scene in the whole
episode we meet Jane for the first time
Jane and his old crew have caught Mal
and Zoe
they start talking about do you get your
own room what share do you get and Jane
is like
I get like 10 cents and I have to share
room with this little hairy over here
and they basically talk Jane into
joining the crew there and there it's
the best interview process I've ever
seen
private room Gene your own room full one
of the kitchen whole shot okay
Jane just turns and shoots one of his
old team in the leg it's actually a
perfect way of introducing the Jane
character who
is a little confrontational at times
let's put it that way
the saviors bring the catalyzer Mal says
look you take whatever you need I just
need that little no part catalyzer and
the crew that have come to save him turn
on Mal and obviously shoot him in the
gut but Mal ain't an idiot he was ready
for the possibility of being double
crossed he'd hidden a weapon and he
pulls it on the uh saviors
he tells them get off my damn ship
and they leave
this is now going into where we see the
beginning of this episode with Mal
injured alone with very little hope
but at least he's got the catalyst
so Mal fights his way through the ship
losing blood dying
desperately trying to get to the engine
room so that he can put this part in the
Kaylee had showed him where it goes
earlier because he has no clue how his
ship works but he knows roughly where
it's going
he's disorientated he can barely stand
he falls over a lot
he never does get to the button that
will call the shuttles back
but then he wakes up and everything's
fine the crew are there the catalyzer's
working the ship is alive again and all
is well
all because Zoe while she was
unconscious couldn't do anything but
when she woke up aboard the shuttle she
demanded they went back immediately and
nobody disagrees with Zoe Washburn
I love how actually Mal is all hooked up
to wash and uh basically getting their
blood transfusion so they're all both a
bit Dopey
yeah try not to speak again the episode
starts with a dead Serenity a cold ship
Mal dying on his own
we see the family that live aboard this
vessel and at the end of the episode
that family does what families do best
they come together and they help each
other when things look their darkest
family really is one of the biggest
themes in Firefly for me and it's also
one of the reasons why I love it so much
they have a dysfunctional Uncle Jane
they have a dad in mouth they have their
little sister and Kaylee
to know it all brother in Simon and the
crazy sister in River
not quite sure where an hour fits in
The Prostitute mom not quite now but
they are a family as dysfunctional as
they are
and the one family member I think I will
miss the most if ever they do return
with firefly reboot his Shepherd book he
was the wise old grandad
and these will be missed
the episode ends with the voice over
again saying hey She's a Beauty you buy
this ship you treat her proper she'll be
with you the rest of your life
and then we look up and it's not the
serenity
Mal turns round
and sees the serenity off in the
distance
and falls in love instantly
Firefly is for me one of the very few
perfect series it didn't go on for long
enough to get ruined Maybe
but out of gas is genuinely one of the
greatest episodes of sci-fi ever made it
is
perfect in every way perfectly written
perfect tone a Brilliance and storyline
that hooks you very early on
that tells you more about the crew we
find out so much more about this show
from this episode than probably any
other episode
it is
sincerely and honestly perfect sci-fi
but guys get to the comments to tell me
what you think is this episode
Perfection what do you actually think of
the Firefly series and what do you think
about the possibility of Disney bringing
it back also I really desperately need
to know what other perfect episodes of
sci-fi are out there that I can then
come along and watch with you if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for a small contribution each
month that really supports the channel
you get to see them without the adverts
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]